during the grey few characters in modern
draggable evoke more debate division and
conflict from their fan base than this
character has done having only made his
debut in the Dragon Ball continuity
towards the beginning of 2017 Geron has
been labeled everything from boring to
stoic from laughable to exhilarating and
everything in between so as I always do
I took to my Twitter to put up a poll
that asked the question did you enjoy
Juran's character the options being yes
and no in 24 hours 3226 votes were cast
leaving a mostly split consensus on the
topic 48 percent claiming they enjoyed
his character while 52 proclaimed they
did not let me know what your thoughts
are here on YouTube click above but
today I will be diving deep into this
volatile contentious topic examining the
story structure of the universe survival
arc identifying where it's false lie and
taking a close look at how Juran's
character plays into the story as its
antagonist and the most powerful fighter
in the multiverse
[Music]
to begin our deconstruction of the
during character let's start with a
quote from Robert bikies book story the
axioms show don't tell warns against
dialogue that substitutes passive
explanations for dynamic dramatizations
to show means to present a scene in an
authentic setting populated with
believable characters struggling towards
their desires to tell means to force
characters to halt their pursuits and
talk instead at a length about their
thoughts and feelings what this means is
in order for your viewers to build a
believable connection with your hero
it's much more effective to see him or
her struggle to see them do something
courageous and brave rather than to hear
that they are struggling or brave for
example the very first time we see Harry
Potter in his first movie he is
celebrating his birthday alone living
with an abusive selfish family sleeping
in a bed under the stairs this
communicates to the viewer visually that
Harry has had a hard life where he's
being wrongfully told that he's
unremarkable and in nuisance but Harry
despite all of this finds the good where
he can and soldiers on and that is
character in the very first episode of
BBC's Sherlock we are introduced to the
titular character as he opens a body bag
to examine it and to beat it with a
riding crop before relaying specific
information to the person working there
to inform him how long it takes before
bruises form this communicates to us
that he is eccentric highly intelligent
and doesn't deal with human interaction
gracefully that again is character this
was the very first time we saw gern and
Dragon Ball super speaking on the topic
of showing off and introducing
characters and stories general
apocalypse had this to say there are
only three ways you can show off your
characters what the character says what
the character does and what others say
about the character those are the three
ways and if you don't have them interact
with anyone the only one you get is what
others say about the character and
that's the worst one of the three
because a lot of it is tell don't show
which you should never do and I can't
say I disagree before we see Jared we
are told that he is impossibly strong
stronger than a god of destruction but
we aren't shown this we are instead
lectured through clunky
unnatural exposition and that's not good
enough it's giving us the information we
need to understand the story but nothing
to understand his character or who he is
or what he wants the first time were
introduced to Vegeta he is seen eating
something he just killed the first time
we meet Frieza he is slaughtering a
namekian village while smiling and the
first time we see cell we find that he
has been preying on the local
inhabitants of a city in the most
terrifying of ways even the character of
Goku black was captivating for a number
of reasons but in addition to that his
unveiling was one of the absolute best
villain debuts in the entire series not
just super the entire series oh my moon
day 2 in this video discussing what
makes a villain feel real super eye
patch wolf points out that the word
antagonist from its Greek roots loosely
translates to mean the one who initiates
change and that's the job of the
antagonist in many ways to be the one
that creates the need for the
protagonist to take specific action and
yet I've described Geron as a passive
antagonist would might think that these
two words should be mutually exclusive
yet here we are he doesn't show interest
in Goku or the tournament he's there out
of obligation much the same way as any
of the other characters he has no
control over the situation beyond his
supposed strength which we still haven't
seen and with that reveals one of the
acts fundamental issues there are two
antagonistic forces in this arc that
cannot work without the other and
neither are working together and what I
mean by that is the tension that forced
the conflict for this arc is the looming
threat of universe sevens destruction
and that tension comes from both the
monumental task of eliminating jiren and
the threat the two zeroes have imposed
on the losers the tension and suspense
comes from both of these things together
at once without the xenos threat of
destroying everyone but the winner the
arc loses all of its sense of suspense
in tension because we don't have any
reason to believe the other universes
would do anything nefarious with the
super Dragon Balls and on the other hand
if Jaron didn't exist then there
wouldn't be any stakes either because
universe 7 would steamroll the
competition which means in theory there
is no villain
there is technically no antagonist the
two forces that are creating the tension
are not working together
so therefore the tension is entirely
circumstantial this is an issue because
defeating Jian is made the goal of the
arc and he alone isn't what creates the
tension in the first place
Moriarty in Sherlock is a captivating
and gripping scene stealer because he is
the one that dictated the pace and
conflict of the entire story up until
that point yes he had more power than
Sherlock much the same way jared has
more power than Goku but power alone
does not a good character make Moriarty
was a great character because he had a
motivation to create conflict that
engaged with Sherlock's specifically his
character was established and we knew
his personality as well as the heroes
and that's the problem
Goku is just another fighter to Gian
until he is told specifically the target
him by another person without knowing
Juran's once his goals his personality
all we had to latch on to as a viewer is
Goku and the rest of the established
cast I don't have anything against Jared
at this point I don't like him or
dislike him and so because of that the
tournament of power is much more like a
sporting event rooting for your team
because hey it's the team you know
rather than an actual story with any
sort of structure tangible antagonistic
force or payoff at least known that
aren't already present in sports games
as a result of this fact the crux of the
narrative lies with Goku and Friends
exclusively burdened in carrying a 54
episode long arc on their shoulders
resulting in universe 7 not engaging
with jarran who was established again as
the goal the major hurdle of the
tournament until episode 109 a whole 13
episodes into the tournament itself
speaking of which
I thought Jordan was at his best when he
first went up against coke since the
only thing established about Jaron was
that he was strong it was interesting to
see how the two would initially interact
with each other
Goku burning through his entire
catalogue of power-ups techniques and
options in a matter of minutes against
Geron was exciting mostly I think
because it was interesting to see how
Goku's flat arc would react to the Geron
situation however due to Jaron not
having enough development or established
character traits to work with Goku
effectively it quickly becomes a
lightshow hinging on a moment worthy of
its own praise the ultra instinct
transformation something Jaron didn't
serve to enhance because on top of
having no established goals or charisma
he also does not a moat for this either
and that's all part of a broader issue
with Jared as John Truby wrote in his
book the anatomy of story create an
opponent who is exceptionally good at
attacking your hero's greatest weakness
and cheerin just doesn't do that he
doesn't seem to have any interest at all
in Goku the only reason he decided in
the first place to give Goku the time of
day was because Bell mode his god of
destruction told him to do so
specifically there isn't a clash of
ideologies we know what Goku's character
stands for and is all about but we have
no concept of what Geron likes thinks
cares about or has contempt for this
story that's being told is about a
tournament a battle royale that is held
by the most elite of the Gods where if
you lose you and your entire universe
get wiped from existence it's been
established that Goku cares about the
value of life but it isn't found out
until the end of the tournament that
jiren does not and when that is
eventually established their fists and
ideologies clash hard something I'd like
to address as my final point when
discussing this final struggle is
suspense and how it's created to work in
great effect within a story to explain
how suspense is created here is a quote
from the master of suspense Alfred
Hitchcock four people are sitting around
the table five minutes of it very dull
suddenly
what does the audience have 10 seconds
of shock now take that same scene and
tell the audience there is a bomb under
that table and will go off in five
minutes well the whole emotion of the
scene is totally different because
you've given them that information
you've got the audience or to use an
example the film your name utilizes this
technique quite masterfully your name is
about two Japanese students taki and
meatza huh as they switch bodies over
the course of the film and ultimately
fall in love however a town shattering
meteor is heading for me to his village
destined to claim her life and those
living there if she doesn't evacuate
herself and the town in time running for
her life the suspense bills as we the
audience see the reflection of the
meteor bounced off the lake to her left
the music swells and then when this
happens as a viewer you were thinking
gee I hope you're okay no but seriously
get moving there's no time
similarly when Frieza announced that
Nemec would explode in five minutes the
tension and suspense rose and came to a
fever pitch near the end as Goku
casually talks with Frieza before
ultimately besting him and giving him
his energy the audience thinks moving
Goku there's no time or inability to
influence the course of events leads to
an experience of tension and that's how
it works
in contrast the torment of power while
it has a time limit at no point was
universe 7 numbering in the fewest
members and so see as the suspense
didn't come from when our heroes get the
job done before the clock runs out it
becomes will they have enough stamina to
wait out the clock which is
significantly less compelling
wanting power and strength isn't an
interesting trait on its own and isn't
necessarily a bad thing but when it's
made clear that you're in values
strength and power over justice and life
he becomes a villain
at the very end of the arc for five
minutes before Goku ultimately defeats
him and he openly gets a Redemption of
sorts after hearing a pep talk from capo
in the following episode you see that
there is a story that's worth telling
but it should have been told over the
course of the entire arc and not a
single episodes runtime there's a very
strong case to be made that I'm sure
many of you are considering right now
that Goku is Juran's antagonist Goku is
the one that initiates every interaction
with the character he forces him to
change and forces him into really tough
situations but there's a problem with
that this story from the get-go was not
set up for jeering to be the protagonist
or even the focus really quite the
opposite and thus he is a character
doesn't service the narrative as
effectively as he should and that's the
problem with the tournament of power it
isn't about a dynamic between characters
it isn't about anything other than a
tournament and that's it every other
tournament in Dragon Ball was about
something rich with character
development and intrigue so I think
saying that the tournament of power was
more like a sporting event and not an
actual story with a payoff is accurate
it was enjoyable in parts with its own
highlights for sure but it wasn't really
a story with the beginning middle and
end no more so than a football game is
there are many things that make this arc
a difficult want to praise narrative Li
but my hope is that being able to
identify the issues with this would-be
antagonist will help you with your own
writing and hopefully to help you all to
avoid making the same mistakes that led
to toy animation creating the
unsatisfying self-contradiction that was
jiren the passive antagonist thanks for
watching
[Music]